hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today I am going to
explain a 2022 fantasy and Adventure
movie called Guardians Of Time Sybil is
the oldest sister in the family she has
a mixed nightmare then wakes up next to
Alex her little sister in the morning
Sybil is already practicing archery
while Alex Races by herself and gets
caught by Papa Nikolai her grandfather
the girls eat their breakfast quickly
because their cousins Zoe and Theo are
about to arrive once they arrive they
commence their Marathon tradition called
nicolathen this year's challenge is
archery the girls take turns shooting
arrows at Targets in the last round
Sybil gets a glimpse of her nightmare
again thus missing the target the winner
is Zoe but Sybil challenges the girls to
a foot race Alex gets disappointed
because she can never win a race then
runs away from the field Alex goes
inside Papa Nikolai study because the
door magically opens she observes the
hourglasses and books meanwhile Sybil
gets a glimpse of the future that Zoe is
about to trip and fall during the race
it really happens so she saves Zoe from
falling and calls the race a draw at the
same time one of the clocks in nikolai's
study advances Alex picks up a few books
and then hides behind the curtain as her
parents and grandfather enter the room
turns out the parents are going on a
research trip and the cousins are about
to be left at the Manor for a while
Nikolai believes the girls can take care
of themselves despite the parents
warning of a tragedy that happened to
Sybil years ago after the meeting
Nikolai discovers Alex behind the
curtain and gives her one of the most
interesting books in his study as the
parents leave Papa Nikolai drives them
to the airport and the girls are left
alone in the manor they play a game of
tag but Alex is not interested and reads
the book Papa Nikolai gave her instead
Sybil finds her in her room and picks
interest in the book they bring the book
to Zoe and Theo then discover an old map
inside it it tells about a time room
between the drawing and study room which
physically cannot exist how however
Sybil reads the Mantra on the map and
although they think it is just gibberish
a door suddenly appears before them they
enter the door and find themselves in
the time room which contains many
magical artifacts Sybil is uncomfortable
due to the black Sparks she keeps seeing
the door changes its scenery now showing
a magical forest the girls decide to go
into the forest despite Sybil's anxiety
they enter the forest and the door
disappears they decide to stick together
and find clues in the book for how to
get back into the manor Alex discovers a
door without a doorknob which is drawn
in the book the book also States
something about a tablet which pieces
are scattered across the forest floor
the girls assemble the tablet piece then
the completed piece magically produces a
creature named a got he explains that
they are in the forest of Forgotten
thoughts he continues that they are the
Warriors for the Guardians of time the
door can only be opened by a tempest key
then they can go anywhere anytime
meanwhile Papa Nikolai comes home woman
searches for the girls he knows they are
missing but does not seem surprised
about it while a God is explaining that
the Tempest key can be reassembled by
gathering three crystals of time two
creatures suddenly teleport and attack
the girls one of them teleports Alex and
a got away from the other girls while
Zoe suddenly stops time when she is
about to be hit by the other creature a
goddess hurt by a poison branch and
states that greya a friend of his can
help so Alex and a god walked to greya's
Castle meanwhile the other girls meet
Shadow and pamfilos a former soldier of
the Atlantean guard they ward off the
tree folk who attacked them pantheolos
explains that they are in keros then
offers to accompany them on their
journey and help fulfill the prophecy
the girls are confused but decide to
walk along meanwhile agat and Alex reach
greya's Castle the powerful sorceress
heals a gut and tells Alex that there
were people who banished her and a got
and made the land lifeless they are gone
now but their presence Echoes it is
prophesied that the guardian millions of
time can reassemble the crystals and
restore order meanwhile pamphelos takes
the girls to a temple where he explains
about keros which is the front of the
conflict between the good forces led by
Prometheus and dark Forces led by
Chronos and the prophecy that Prometheus
descendants will save the realm from
Kronos and become guardians of time
there are three crystals of time that
the Guardians need to obtain to ensure
the good sides win which are
chronoception chronometry and chronology
however they are located at different
temples the girls deduce that Papa
Nikolai is a powerful Titan and they are
the prophesied Guardians pamphalos takes
the girls to the ruins of Avalon where
he hides devices that could be useful
for the girls in their Journey the
device transforms each girl into a
warrior since only the descendants of a
Titan can enter the temples of time they
must be the Guardians who can obtain the
crystals not other creatures the Temple
of chronoception is located near Gray's
Castle but Alex is afraid to commence
the mission greya shows her the seeing
Stone which shows her Amelia Earhart's
plane the Atlantis Kingdom and finally
her sister and cousins Alex thinks that
the girls are having fun without her
with panfellows and do not care about
her she becomes determined to obtain the
crystal of conception a god takes her
there and she subsequently enters the
Temple of chronicception meaning the
perception of time she observes that as
she moves forward the temple crumbles
but if she walks backward time moves
back restoring the temple to its full
Glory she unlocks the Crystal and goes
out meanwhile Sybil Zoe and Theo enter
the Temple of chronometry or measurement
of time Zoe asks pamphelos about her
powers to which he replies that each
descendant of a Titan naturally has
powers that may help them in their
mission inside the temple Theo gets a
headache she suddenly remembers
everything from the past including
passages from the book which enables her
to figure out a way to unlock the
crystal they get the Crystal and Escape
safely the girls camp at night panthelos
sets an enchantment Circle which text
them from the darkness or the remains of
Kronos Army Sybil relives her nightmare
which was thought of as a trauma
response to when she broke into Nikolai
study then got off to find a stranger
standing in front of her panthelos
deduces the dream as a vision meanwhile
Alex stays in greya's Castle while agat
seeks to find the other girls graya
helps unlock Alex's power which turns
out to be the most powerful of all
guardians of time she possesses all
powers of the past present and future
while her sister and cousins only
possess one each greya transforms into a
dragon which threatens Alex but she can
use her power to defend herself then
greya puts her to sleep the next day
agath finds pamphelos and the girls
panthelos offers him breakfast but I got
declines they walk to the Temple of
chronometry Alex wakes up to find greya
has just finished a conversation with a
God she tells her that a god finds her
family but pamfilos intends to take the
Crystal from them Alex is determined to
find the girls on her own so she unlocks
the Crystal's power which makes her
older than she actually is during the
journey the girls ask pamphelos how he
and his army managed to defeat diamonds
Chronos most powerful Lieutenant he
explains that they imprisoned him in a
tablet the girls thinking about the
tablet they reassembled earlier deduced
that a gut is Dimos in Disguise Dimas
wants the power of the crystals not the
Tempest key they proceed carefully and
walk behind a god they arrive at the
temple but nothing happens when the
three girls pass the Temple Gate turns
out Alex already obtained the crystal
all by herself attention breaks out as
Alex believes the other girls are not
looking for her and hanging out with a
boy instead while Sybil and the cousins
believe Alex has been used by Dimos
panthelos casts a spell that breaks
Daimos disguise Alex already gave him
one of the crystals guilt written Alex
unleashes her powers and cannot control
them but Sybil refuses to give up on her
sister she uses her Crystal breaks
through Alex's magic wall all and takes
her hand Alex's Powers come back to
normal and so does her younger
appearance however graya comes in her
Dragon form the girls reassemble the
crystals then they travel back in time
they relive the confrontation again then
Dimas notices them the girls travel back
in time again but they realize they have
to change a variable to escape the time
Loop and win over Daimos and greya Dimas
exclaims that he does not want the
Crystal's Powers he wants to destroy it
so he could revive Chronos he breaks the
crystal of chronology in his hand Zoe
uses her power to stop time while the
girls think of their next move they then
realize Sybil's power is foreseeing the
future so she should be able to see a
way where they can win over Daimos Alex
fixes the broken Crystal of chronology
then Sybil uses it for her mind to
travel back through time she arrived
when she got into nikolai's study then
she touched a strange circular tablet
and noticed a bag when she got out of
the room she bumped into a stranger
which turned out to be Dimas but
suddenly Papa Nikolai appeared before
her causing Daimos to run away back to
her current situation Sybil realizes the
thing she touched was the Tempest key
and she had placed it inside the bag
that Alex used to store her book The key
is inside the bag all along so the girls
rushed to find it and place the crystals
on it they used their combined power to
defeat daimas while greya is defeated by
Shadow they thank panthelos and then
teleport back home Papa Nikolai gladly
Embraces them back to karos pamphelos is
seen talking to a mysterious guy that
asks him whether he tells the girls the
truth to which he replies that he only
told them what they needed to know
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching